hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here
coming back at you from Las Vegas and
who would have thought the coolest booth
at CES 2015 would be a car company so
obviously there's tons of stuff at CES
that's really cool obviously to check
out and there are more videos on that
stuff to come but when you think of
hi-tech you rarely think of the ancient
hundred-year-old car industry and I've
talked about stuff that I guess Tesla's
done in the past year or so but BMW this
year had a legitimately awesome booth at
CES worth checking out so starting with
the BMW i8 totally dope looking car if
you couldn't already tell if you haven't
seen it I have some more stuff with that
coming up soon but if you don't already
know the i8 is one of the most badass
hybrid cars in the world with a
combination of an engine that has the
gas tank and an electric motor with
batteries that need to be charged now
I've showed off wireless charging of
phones in the past but leave it to BMW
to introduce inductive wireless charging
in their car so they're working on
basically driving up onto an inductive
wireless charging mat in your garage and
you're charging the battery at almost
the same rate as if you were physically
plugged in and here's another thing the
BMW m4 so this is their flagship sports
car right now essentially and they had a
showing with these concept lights on the
car oh LED tail lights and laser
headlights which seemed a little bit
weird but there are a ton of things that
this can become useful for the olla
taillights could theoretically be any
color you want and create any pattern or
any color and any frame rate which is
crazier basically using your tail lights
as a display on the back of your car but
they looked really sharp the only thing
I'd be hesitant about is if olee tail
lights would be bright enough obviously
they're doing this demo in a dark demo
showroom where everything's supposed to
be dark already but I would hope that
they're also light and visible outdoors
and regular light but still they looked
pretty dope and then there's the laser
headlights they turn on automatically at
night and they're on all the time to
eliminate 650 yards in front of you now
you don't think you want your headlights
on full high-beam all the time seems
like a bad idea but there is intelligent
lighting involved sensors decide where
to highlight dark areas on the road in
front of you and it'll also
intelligently cut out a patch of the
laser headlights
to not blind the car on the other side
of the road in front of you or an
oncoming traffic so this is basically
the way headlights should be disclaimer
Laser headlights aren't exactly legal in
the United States right now but they
would totally should be so this is just
a concept that's basically a year out
for BMW over in Europe still awesome
they also showed gesture controls from a
sensor in the car roof for the BMW
idrive system they have a backseat
tablet that's meant to be able to
control the heating in the car or other
features before you even get in or after
they have a new key fob for the i8
hybrid that will remotely let you check
on how that Wireless charge doing or
will check on another car status stuff
like your door locks all of these things
are future plans that are down the road
for them pun intended but the
best-looking demos of this booth for
them were from the pretty tame looking
BMW i3 I know you see the i8 and it
looked super sharp and their m4 is such
a sporty car but the i3 has a lot of
tricks up its sleeve first there was a
crash avoidance demo where the car
literally stops itself before an
obstacle even if you're stopping on the
gas and then there was a final trick
that just kind of blew everyone's mind
summoning the thing from a SmartWatch
so there you go guys it was pretty
surreal sitting in the backseat of a car
that was driving itself with no one else
in it but it was a lot of fun to check
out what BMW had at the booth this year
and I got my eye on them especially with
that i8 and look out for the future i8
video I have coming later on this
channel either way thanks for watching
stay tuned for more videos
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace